when was the last time you watched an
anime that really had an effect on you
no I'm not talking about the last anime
you enjoyed the last time you had a cute
wife rewar husband oh you cheerfully
followed along with the last time you
laughed or cried during a show I'm
talking about the one that really made
you rethink something in your actual
life one whose area of effect extended
beyond the confines of the screen you
are watching it on that's embedded
itself deep into your psyche long after
you had finished watching it it's a
bittersweet feeling whenever you get it
because as you grow older that feeling
becomes increasingly harder to find
mostly because the older you get the
more you learn about yourself and the
world around you that it becomes rarer
for you to find something that really
makes you reflect on an aspect of
yourself in a different light so today I
wanted to share my experiences around
the latest show that managed to have
this effect on me and that was with a
place further than the universe now if
you've kept up with the anime seasons or
even just my Twitter you probably
already know about this show as it's
made its rounds on the community as the
new critically acclaimed show of last
season but you know past all the hype
and the praise of its writing and
direction and technical aspects that
people normally talk about for me it was
one of the most inspirational anime I've
ever had the pleasure of viewing it's
been a long time since I've seen the
show that's affected an audience on such
an intimate level and I was definitely
one of them and all it is is about a
group of normal high school girls that
journey to Antarctica which many people
have already happily pointed out that
that is still very much within this
universe here's a little tangent about
myself as a person as a kid I was a
daydreamer I'd spend so much of my time
in my own head that people thought I was
this really quiet uninteresting Asian
kid that didn't have too many friends
because in my head I daydream about
going on these grand adventures and
doing something
citing one day even though I was just a
lazy nerd who rarely got out of his room
um but I think that was why I was so
drawn to the escapism in anime and why I
was so intimately drawn to this show
right from episode 1 when we are
introduced to one of the girls who wakes
up one day and realizes that she feels
like she's wasting her youth she hasn't
done all the crazy things she wanted to
do and cliche as this may be I'm sure
it's a feeling everyone's had at least
one time in their lives you have these
plans you have these ambitions that you
tell yourself you will eventually get to
someday someday but not today today you
have school or today you have a job or
you're just not feeling up for it or you
have commitments or it's just not the
right time then days past weeks months
then eventually years and that someday
never becomes today a lot of the times
we are just waiting for that one thing
to push us over the edge and many of us
never stop waiting but in the show's
case she meets someone who couldn't be
more different from her someone who had
the craziness and eccentricities she
didn't who was not going to let anything
or anyone get in the way of achieving
her own ambitions which was to go to
Antarctica that was her push that was
her signal and seeing her take that
first fearful step towards the journey
she always wanted hits me so much harder
than I thought it would and plastered
this smile on my face that wouldn't be
removed throughout the whole show
I remember thinking man if they get to
Antarctica in Episode three and this
turns out to be a mo a show about a
bunch of cute girls [ __ ] around with
penguins I'm going to be so disappointed
but luckily it only expanded on moments
like this on the journey that they
undertake and the bonds that they make
it's so energetically captured that
spirit of youthful adventure seizing the
day and all that cheesy inspirational
crap you've heard before but portraying
it in a way that feels so close to home
not as a quest with stakes bigger than
people involved but as a personal
journey one shared with the friends you
hold most dear with a destination that
was as breathtaking as the journey that
took us there there's a scene in episode
7 I think where the girls are on this
ship to their destination and it's the
first time they've child why see so of
course it's the first time they've
experienced seasickness and it's just an
absolutely awful time they can't sleep
they can't eat they're constantly
feeling like complete crap and yet it
turns into this little bonding
experience for the group like the girls
should start laughing because they're
having an absolutely awful time but
they're having an awful time together
and that's what doesn't make it so bad I
love this scene anyone who's been on a
trip with friends knows that nothing
goes exactly to plan something always
goes wrong and you may end up
experiencing new things that you're you
know you're not too fond of but um it's
sharing this experience this journey
through its ups and downs with the
people you care about that really
secures the bonds you have with them
it's those moments that you'll look back
on together in years time and laughs
that has a tender memory even if at the
time you absolutely hated it and that's
kind of the beauty of this show that it
manages to hit on such a human level it
isn't an incredibly deep show but it is
a tender reminder of aspects many of us
can find in ourselves whether it be the
feeling like you're wasting your youth
that you need to do something to come to
terms with an event in your life putting
on a brave face even though all you want
to do is kick and scream on the inside
or Never finding the friend
who really cared about you watching
these characters grow over the course of
their journey and fill in these aspects
that they were missing in their lives
has this incredible power to ignite this
desire to fill in some of the gaps in
your own life and that to me was way
more powerful than the C's of
motivational posters quotes and speeches
I've seen floating around on the
Internet
but I guess that's just it we've become
desensitized to a lot of the things we
see through a screen reality shows
commercialize they're relatable sob
story news turn tragedies into
compelling narratives social media has
put a glassy filter over everyone's
lives that it's hard to distinguish
what's real anymore it's so easy to
become cynical with the amount of
[ __ ] we are exposed to in this ever
more connected world but maybe that's
why something as innocently faker's for
cue anime girls felt way more real and
was able to blindside the cynical voice
in the back of my head that tells me not
to get swayed over something like this
when the show ended I was greeted with a
bittersweet void I hadn't felt in so
long I didn't want to watch any other
anime I didn't want to immediately log
online and share my opinion I just
wanted to let it sink in and truly
reflect on the experience it had given
me and when I realized that I just
thought how long has it been since I've
felt this feeling how long has it been
since I truly cherished what a show
could do and really let it run its
course and that brings me to what I was
saying at the beginning every so often
you find that anime or that movie or
that song there has a profound effect on
your life and makes you think deeper
about yourself and it really sticks with
you for a while that feeling is becoming
harder and harder to find in this day
and age not just because you get older
but because we consume so much media now
that new things are constantly pushed in
our face that we don't even have time to
reflect on the last thing we watched to
let it sink in and I don't know if I'm
being old-fashioned in feeling like when
you always have something to move on to
immediately you forget to hold on to the
things that you find truly special
and I think it's something we're slowly
losing in this modern world of abundancy
so I decided to do something stupid I
decided to let myself be inspired by
this innocent show go on a journey to a
place I've never been before and do
things I had never done without any
pressure to keep up with anime or the
internet because I wanted to remember
remember why anime had such a big effect
on me when I was younger remember the
craziness I felt when I abandoned my
career to pursue this medium as a job
remember that Ashok me more than just a
commodity we watched discussed and
forget and cement myself that just
because I felt inspired by a fictional
constructed story of four cute girls
doing something amazing with their lives
it doesn't mean the experience was any
less real for me because it wasn't
[Music]
that's really what I wanted to get off
my chest I'm not sure if I was trying to
say anything aside from hey I think this
is a pretty good show and you should
give it a shot but for me it reminded me
a few things I might have known but have
forgotten over the years it reminded me
that I value looking at the world
through an optimistic lens it reminded
me to value the bonds I've made to work
with the friends that I have and as
someone who did do something as reckless
with their life as quitting their career
they had some years of their life into
for an Internet job it was my personal
reminder that I could turn that someday
into today
[Music]